die rollenverteilung nach dem krieg
wackler frauchen diente dem wohle des
mannes
und dieser revanchierte sich mit
pfiffigen ideen zur schönheitspflege
katharina wollte mehr sein als ein
schmuckes anhängsel und so ging sie 1953
auf weltreise
ohne geld in der tasche allein mit mut
und ihrer ukulele der autor und
dokumentarfilmer wilfried meichtry hat
sich in das archiv eines widerständigen
lebens eingegraben und auch die gründe
für ihre gewagte weltreise gefunden
die schweiz ist rafael sein woche aber
natürlich keiner vorstellen dass sie
irgendwie klassische rolle nimmt wirkt
und den in der küche steht und quasi der
mann die pantoffeln bereithalten wenn du
aber hält und natürlich kommen sie ihre
rolex sie hat wieder finden wir die
eigentlich was mache ich mit dem lappen
und gesetzlicher schweiz nicht kann will
sie jetzt von überall her erwartet
gespielt verträgen familie
sie reisten einfach per anhalter
selbst mit schiffen und flieger
verdiente reisegeld mit zeichnungen oder
sinkt im indischen radio vor luzern
gaddafis zur katharina tätern us
fernsehshows auf als hit schreibt swiss
miss und kehrt als angehende berühmtheit
zurück nach zürich
19 56 erscheint ihre weltreise per
anhalter eine schweizer zeitschrift
schickt die junge reise schriftstellerin
noch im selben jahr in die südsee zur
königin von tonga zusammen mit dem
fotografen freddy dringen
das erhoffte foto mit der königin
bekommt katharina nicht
sie bekommt den fotografen er ist im
haus genauso gleichen abend direktive
sie ein romantiker ob sie ja eigentlich
reisende in jedem sinkt sie unterwegs
wie sie und das hat sie sehr verbunden
und maxi sie heiratet er mal was ich für
ihre arbeit interessiert sie gehen nun
gemeinsam auf expeditionen besuchen
kannibalen und völker die noch nie
kontakt mit weißen hatten katharina
schreibt freddy fotografiert und schießt
eines der bekanntesten fotos von mir
über das sie witzelt hier sei sie vom
kannibalen häuptling zum essen
eingeladen worden
es wurde das titelbild der schweizer
zeitschrift sie und er ihre lebens
bahnen verlaufen fortan parallel zwei
aussteiger und querdenker aber auch zwei
liebende deren geschichte wilfried
meichtry bis 2017 verfilmen will einen
teil konnte er vor dem tod von katharina
von arx 2013 drei andere sequenzen sind
mit schauspielern nachgestellt
eine liebesgeschichte in briefen
gegangen und ich bin traurig meine große
liebe
ich umarme dich so wie ich dich liebe
sehr sehr stark ihr fällig erinnern sie
sich an diesen noch ja das war eine
schöne zeit das ende dieser zeit beginnt
auf einer fahrt durchs watt land die sie
später so beschreibt nebelschwaden
hängen zwischen den schwarzen zeigen und
ließen den wald noch tiefer erscheinen
dann auf einmal ein rötlicher schimmer
der nebel sich und gab den blick auf
alte dächer frei vor uns lag das reine
mittelalter oma otti sie kaufen ein haus
die verfallene schönheit entpuppt sich
als altes pilger aus das letzte seiner
art aber auch ein haus das alles geld
alle zeit und alle energie verschlingt
eine menage a trois wurde katharina der
freddy und süß und englisch ist die
friendly außen vor allem sammler dass
sie das restaurieren und der freddy als
der intellektuelle war eigentlich in der
katharina verliebtes chihuahua reist war
unabhängig war anti material ist ist
natürlich freuen immer wieder erkannt
sie entfremden sich
freddy zieht aus gegen alle widerstände
will katharina den geist des alten prior
hauses wieder beleben wie einst für
pilgerreisen de soll es auch heute
wieder ein haus für alle sein reiche
festgesellschaften die arme
durchreisende ich glaube hier versucht
ihre fantasie von gewalt wie sich anti
sie euch an die sie umsetzen wir zum
beispiel akzent dass sich letztendlich
wichtiger als ich die später heimat eine
abenteurerin einst ausgezogen aus einer
engstirnigen schweiz soll ihr haus nun
aller welt offenstehen